You’re an indie game developer,
passionate about bringing your next big mobile game to life.
You know the quest is not going to be easy.
But you are ready to face any challenge in the search for the elusive 5 star rating...
...a voyage that leads to a game that is loved and played by many.
Whether you are crafting a brand-new space adventure,
or creating a role-playing game full of monsters and magic,
we know that trying to rise to the top can feel like a tough climb.
What if there was a way to supercharge your game?
Introducing Indie Games Accelerator by Google Play.
A program to fast track your growth and give your game that real boost.
Get direct coaching on game development best practices from top gaming experts and Google mentors!
Attend all-expenses-paid gaming bootcamps at Google Asia’s headquarter in Singapore!
Where you’ll learn everything about building a successful gaming company!
Apply for the program today to give your game the next level-up!